So if you go back, we talked about games.
Another important class of applications is
content, newspapers, magazines.
When you read a magazine, it is a really nice
experience. So how do you create that same
experience on the Web?
This is an important problem, and we have
reached out to magazine publishers to help
create these experiences. To show what you
can do in terms of producing content on the
Web, I would like to invite Terry McDonnell
who is the editor of Sports Illustrated.
[ Applause ]
>>Terry McDonnell: Walking out here it occurred
to me that I might be the oldest person in
the room.
[ Laughter ]
>>Terry McDonnell: But this is fine with me.
In my business, still standing is a very good
thing.
My brand, Sports Illustrated, is a monster
traditional brand. Storied, extremely lucrative,
started from a very simple idea, self-defining,
becoming more and more complicated. And now,
changing faster than it ever has.
And it's not just Sports Illustrated.
In my company, Time, Inc., every single one
of the iconic brands, and I am talking about
People, Fortune, Entertainment Weekly and
Time, is changing very fast also.
The reason for this is that empowered engineers
and developers like all of you in this room
are, in turn, empowering and helping me as
an editor to create new versions of Sports
Illustrated.
That's why I'm here.
I'm going to start with a video here, and
then we will go live. The video hopefully
will have a little swagger to it and it will
show you sort of where we are coming from
at Sports Illustrated.
It starts with the first cover in 1954.
(Video Playing)
>>Terry McDonnell: Okay. We are live now.
Driving today is the always the dangerous
David Link, founder of the Wonderfactory and
S.I.'s development partner in creating this
live HTML5 prototype that will hopefully show
some of the possibilities of bringing an enriched
magazine to laptops, netbooks and tablets.
It's really -- he is opening it in the Chrome
store.
It's really a very simple idea.
It's to somehow pull together the best of
the Web, the best of the magazine. This came
off fresh yesterday in Merced, our plant in
Merced.
To pull out the absolute most important things
in the DNA in the magazine and translate them
in a way that they are even more enjoyable,
like the photography for example. This goes
very deep for us. We have staff photographers,
one of the most popular things we have.
And the rest of it of course.
What I am talking about here is a tightly
edited, curated, free, open, social, searchable
take on sports that you can customize for
yourself by rearranging it.
It's also going to have, of course, live video
feeds, live news, live scores, like we have
here.
All of this built on a foundation of strong
journalism and informed opinion about the
stories of the moment, like Tiger here.
And additional content that in fact will pull
new further, that will allow you to participate
in this sports world.
This is a poll that we are doing live right
now about how to build a baseball franchise.
It's not necessarily good news for the Giants.
This is one of our sports columns. We have
one of these every week. This is boxing which
is enriched by a video which happened outside
the room, behind the velvet ropes in the background.
(Video Playing)
>>Terry McDonnell: You don't want to mess
with Floyd.
>>> I believe in my skills and I believe in
my talent.
>>Terry McDonnell: And of course here is hockey,
here is your golf, here is your NFL. Always
need video there, always need highlights,
these of the number one draft choice, Sam
Bradford out of Oklahoma.
Of course you might want to not watch this
now, might want to save it for later which
you can do here.
But most important, I think, is to always
know where you are in this magazine so you
can find what you want and go directly to
it.
For example, here is a piece on the end of
the road for Shaq.
[ Laughter ]
>>Terry McDonnell: Kind of a bad call.
The typography here is very, very important,
because you came here to read this story,
and nothing retards reading like the formula
fonts that we are so used to online. And say
here, here is a strong portrait of Shaq. We
can deliver for you the video of this photo
shoot and how we put that cover together.
We can do this.
(Video Playing)
>>Terry McDonnell: The idea also that you
need to go deeper is very important because
you might want additional stories about Shaq
and his future.
There they are.
You might want to go wider. You might want
to go into the NBA to see about Lebron, or
you might want to just see pictures of the
last time they played together and see what
that was like.
And finally you probably want to share any
and/or all of this with your friends or whoever,
and you have a number of choices there.
And as you are running through this, you can
always keep up with what other NBA fans are
thinking and saying about the league on Google
Buzz.
All of this stuff works very hard for the
user. And the advertising I think has to work
very hard, too.
No more image messaging, really.
What we need is stuff that is actually useful.
So this advertising, I submit to you, can
become so useful that it becomes content in
and of itself.
This is a new idea in advertising.
Or it's not a new -- It would be new to actually
deliver it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>>Terry McDonnell: You can -- But as you see
here, you can change the lens and see what
that's like. And then of course you want to
buy it, so we can show you where to buy it.
So what you can see that we are going for
here is additional content of every kind,
content that is enriched and of the moment
and feels different and right, and like a
magazine experience, like nothing else that
you see on the Web today.
And when it is on the point of the most important
stories of the moment in sports, say like
in this case the impact of soccer on world
peace coming into the World Cup, this is a
very good and interesting thing for us to
be working on.
There we go.
Now, like I said, this came off the press
in Merced. It is that.
Some of that was a little bit different, but
it was live, but this is something that we're
very, very excited about coming forward with.
And the reason for that is that in the fall
of last year, not long after S.I. released
a video demo of what an enriched magazine
might look like on a tablet, I found myself
in a very small conference room in Mountain
View, and it hit me there that I was at the
beginning of a veritable storm of innovation
that might not be so new in Mountain View,
but that was going to allow the journalism
that I want and that my company Time, Inc.,
stands for to flourish and to completely reimagine,
remake the business model to support it.
So I'm thinking about, you know, that quote
in the sports movie "Field of Dreams" where
he says, "If you build it, they will come."
I would add an addendum to that. It has to
be built open, it has to be well edited, it
has to be searchable, it has to be social,
and it has to be everywhere.
And if we do that, we can charge for it.
It's great to be with you.
[ Applause ]